[Music]  hi guys i'm lauren zima Monday night on  The Bachelorette was part one of a two  night event but plenty of drama was  packed into those two hours especially  again between Kenny and Lee it's out of  hand I'm listening to you and I was just  like I don't even know how to respond to  it  Rachel's an attorney but she had to play  judge on their two-on-one date not  shockingly these sewer pitted against  each other and not shockingly we did not  get the conclusion but we did see Rachel  make some very real love connections  with Peter and Brian Brian got a  one-on-one date Peter got some hot tub  time do you want to cover it in the hot  tub  let's do it these two are very quickly  coming to the forefront of contenders  for me who's your favorite let me know  over on Twitter  [Music]  you